hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's einen schokoladenkuchen und
zwar einen mississippi
das ist eigentlich eine tat weil man hat
umso einen mürbeteig und im innern ist
eine richtig leckere schokolade gecremt
daher kommt auch der name
das ist ein amerikanisches rezept wird
später serviert mit etwas geschlagener
sahne und zartbitterschokolade und ich
muss jetzt zuerst einmal den mürbeteig
herstellen
jetzt freu mich richtig drauf für den
mittag brauche ich 200 gramm mehl 25
gramm kakaopulver 110 gramm butter 55
gramm zucker eine prise salz etwas sonne
legt und einen espresso den espresso
habe jetzt bereits ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen
ich stelle es direkt mit dem mob teig
und zwar kommt die butter die es noch
kalt und den kleinen stückchen
geschnitten in einer rührschüssel
gemeinsam mit dem zucker und dem man den
extrakt und das wird jetzt kurz
miteinander verrührt alternativ könnt
ihr zum beispiel auch einen mixer nehmen
oder die hände
jetzt kommen die restlichen zutaten mit
rein und hier im blick habe ich jetzt
kein oder kein geld mit dabei dafür habe
ich hier den espresso und jetzt gebe ich
einfach mal ein bisschen espresso rhein
nicht so viel damit der teig jetzt auch
nicht zu feucht wird und dann könnt ihr
einfach mal kontrollieren wenn ihr euch
etwas teig rausnimmt und wenn der teig
dann schon beim zusammendrücken zusammen
bleibt dann ist die konsistenz genau
richtig dann brauche ich keine nespresso
mehr
und falls sie etwas zu viel ist also
drin habt könnt ihr einfach noch ein
bisschen mehl dazugeben also so kündet
ihr dental den tag auch wieder retten
falls einmal doch zuvor stand
den teig gibt es jetzt hier auf die
arbeitsfläche und formen zu einer kugel
jetzt muss einen kühlschrank noch mal
ruhen dafür lege ich ihnen ganz flach in
eine schale
so wird er nämlich schneller kalt also
schneller wir jetzt eine teil kugel
macht dann kommt der deckel drauf und
der teig ins land von 30 minuten in den
kühlschrank
der teig ist schön kalt und jetzt kann
ich ihn ausräumen und es geht am besten
wenn man ihnen vorher ein bisschen
durchkneten
ich habe hier bereits eine backform
gerichtet und zwar einen bug rahmen auf
28 cm eingestellt und unten dran blicken
backpapier jetzt hole ich den teig aus
und muss dann zuerst unten den boden
ausbreiten
dann kann ich die backform nehmen wunsch
den kreis ausstechen und mit hilfe eines
torten retters setze ich den teigboden
jetzt direkt aufs blech und kann dann
direkt die backform wiederum stellen
und aus dem rest rolle ich jetzt noch
mal ein ganz langes band aus und es soll
3 cm breit sein damit er an 3 cm hoch
wird
und den überschuss schneide stand mit
einem messer weg
aus dem teig christen könnt ihr jetzt
super leckere kekse backen
das mache ich auch gleich aber den teig
stecke ich jetzt noch mit einer gabel
mehrmals ein
so bleibt der teig nämlich beim banken
schön flach den ofen habe ich jetzt
übrigens auch bereits vorgeheizt auf 190
grad ober unterhitze und da muss datei
gibt es für 15 minuten vor gebacken
werden ohne in der zwischenzeit kann ich
schon mal die füllung vorbereiten
der mississippi maffay besteht aus einer
richtig cremigen und seth rogen füllung
ich habe schon im teig ganz viel
kakaopulver habe noch espresso mit dabei
und die füllung ist auch noch so ein
richtig dunkle schokolade gefüllt und
dafür brauche ich 150 g weiche butter
200 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
vier eier 300 milliliter sahne 200 gramm
herren schokolade das ist schokolade mit
mindestens 70 prozent kakaoanteil und 30
kakaopulver nämlich zuerst die butter
gebe es in eine rührschüssel und die
sollte weich sein damit man sie auch
gleich richtig cremig rühren kann
das ist so ein richtiger kuchen für mich
denn ich liebe zarter schokolade und
kakao kakaobaum nach marca kann cacau
na ja auf jeden fall ich mag eine dunkle
schokolade deswegen ist es der perfekte
kuchen für mich da noch ein bisschen
meinl extrakt rein und jetzt so etwa
drei bis vier minuten cremig rühren und
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
die sahne aufkochen
sobald die sahne koch nämlich die vom
herd herunter und die schokolade ein
dank an die sich nämlich schon auflösen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die eier nacheinander in die butter
zucker mischung einrühren immer 1 1 nach
dem anderen kurz warten bis es verrührt
ist uns an das nächste
die schokolade hat sie jetzt aufgelöst
sie ist ganz aufgelöst
und da kommt noch das kakaopulver mit
rein
jetzt lasse ich die schokolade ganz
langsam mit reinlaufen die füllung
werdet direkt ihnen vorgebackenen teig
gegossen und dann muss ich den backofen
runterschalten auf 160 grad und kuchen
in 45 minuten fertig
der kuchen ist abgekühlt und ich habe
ihn im kühlschrank noch etwa eine stunde
kühlen lassen und so sieht er jetzt aus
als im ofen geht ja etwas hoch und dann
wieder ab er reist dann auch ein aber
das ist gar nicht schlimm ich finde eine
woche wirklich wunderschön vor allem
zieht man jetzt auch hier im innern so
ein bisschen dieser schlammige
konsistenz der kuren hat ja auch den
namen mississippi maffay und eben
deswegen weil es eben hier aus dem
schlamm und zwar kommt er aus
mississippi und man sagt dass der kuchen
dieses inneres so aussieht wie der
schlamm an den ufern des mississippi
dabei müssen sie gefällt mir war es ein
ich habe mein buch statt vier
wettbewerber geworden cpm
doppel s wie doppel s ii doppelpass
damit noch mal rückwärts doppel s doppel
s ii doppel im fast auf jeden fall ist
der kuchen sondern nicht fertig
traditionell wird er in den usa gerne
auch mit eiscreme serviert ich werde
allerdings seine seine schicht drauf
machen braucht dafür 300 gramm sahne
drei teelöffel sabbath und für die deko
später noch etwas zarter qualcomm in
manila schmeckt aber auch richtig folge
definitiv wahnsinn
jetzt kommt die sache hier rein mit kurz
angeschlagen und dann kommen die drei
teelöffel seiner blatt mit dazu
normalerweise würde jetzt hier plane
darauf streichen und den kuchen dann so
servieren
aber irgendwie gefällt mir der kuchen so
richtig gut vor allem wenn die sonne mal
drauf ist muss der kuchen eben auch an
dem tag noch serviert werden oder am
nächsten aber ich finde es echt schöner
ich las es ist getrennt voneinander aber
ich würde es kochen und kann jetzt schon
mal die schokolade in unsere stücke
schneiden und an servieren wir das
gleich zusammen mit richtung
das sieht aus wie an den ufern des
mississippi wenn das wasser wieder
zurück läuft und dann lassen wir
rutschen um diese erde und das wasser
gigantisch und das darfst du jetzt
probieren
ach ja das ist echt mein kuchen
vor allem diese kruste dies soll so ganz
leicht knusprig genau man kann ja auch
für sauber und keiner merkt man sagt
einfach also ausgeschlossen
und da gehört so kommt er jetzt gibt's
eine gabe die oberfläche jetzt nicht
nicht kaputt machen
mag schon mal verkauft ja ich mir ja
oh mein gott
das ganze hass und gewalt
das ist sowieso ein saftig ist ein
riesengroßer machen in runder
riesengroßer traum ja so ähnlich
also das ist auch richtig saftig wie
sonnen also wenn ja wenn jetzt mal wenn
ihr auf wenn ihr auf diese mcdonald's
kopie steht oder wir subway cookies dann
müsste ich mal diesen kuchen probieren
weil das ist wirklich gigantisch als
jeder kobe wo es bei irgendwelchen zu
fetten ketten gibt was fast food fällt
dann einfach so anrichten
das sind gigantische dann macht
vielleicht noch sonder himbeere oder so
eine erdbeere als kontrast und jetzt was
guten appetit
das ist ja der 19 und ich finde es war
die beste entscheidung die sahne nicht
trocken ja noch nach der heirat mit mir
also hier dass ich richtig ist richtig
toll aus und jetzt nachzieht richtig
saftig test aber was ferien der saane
david gangs vanille extra klein dass sie
ist einfach gigantisch kannst du morgen
die arbeitnehmer kann nicht gerne machen
ist doch so ein richtiger richtig toller
schokokuchen oder für alle
schokoladenfirma also irgendwas ganz er
sagt das ist mit abstand der beste
schokolade kuchen
du kriegst morath sie also ich hab nicht
vorstellbar ist doch besser und roland
google vor allem so kalt aus dem
kühlschrank und im sommer wirklich gerne
mit einer kugel eis oder wobei ich das
sein mag weil ich finde ich manchmal ein
bisserl zu kalt vergesst alles an
deutschland als mal der andere zug
verlässt okay das ist ein abstand der
beste kuchen also sehr wahrscheinlich
alle lust auf diesen kurven bekomme ich
ja dann könnt ihr das rezept nachlesen
dallas - blog.de dann stets noch mal
genau dem morath ich glaube ich hätte
den puck und macht gleich meine fotos
für den block 2000 kalorien ich jetzt
schon mal ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken
und wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
richtig gut und hat so hübsch aus ist
man da schon wieder weg der einfachste
weg